floyd and them they know i'm a muslim
they you know they always respect me and
no i have never heard anything like that
have you have you ever had a chance to
sit down and have a deep conversation
with someone like floyd did he ever ask
you about islam did he ever
you know because i mean when african
americans when they look back at their
roots
you look at you know that islam this is
when malcolm x right when muhammad ali
when they went back and they dug
and they saw that you know this is my
roots islam submission to the creator
not the creation
islam you know this is the roots of the
african-american people
uh has he ever you know asked you any
questions about islam have you ever any
any any talk about it um not yet
not yet but inside in the future
do you think someone like let's say
tomorrow hypothetically if uh floyd
mayweather if he really looked into this
deen which is based on proof and
evidence if you read the quran and he
said man this is from the creator of the
heavens and earth and he decided to
submit
his will to allah to the creator and now
do you think someone like him you know
him right
uh do you think he would he would be
someone who would need uh
to think someone like him he would just
have to have four wives
four it's four there's a maximum four i
i'll take four whites yeah probably but
uh
because islam is practical islam is
practical so this might be a way for
some dawah opportunity right because a
man's like thinking man he wants to be
right he wants to be married but how can
i and you're out there but man
it gives him a a a a good great option
to be right with his creator
and to do it uh you know the way that's
sanctioned by by
[Music]
yeah sure yeah that's beautiful
alhamdulillah you can drop them here and
there you know some of these things
have a person think because i remember i
did a program
i did a program once i remember when he
was in jail
yeah yeah that was years back and we
were talking about that you know it's
like when everything gets taken away
and same thing when you're in the grave
tomorrow when you die
i mean sorry some people are just like
spooked out right now but this is a
reality we're gonna die
and we need to think why are we here
where are we going when we die
you know and i remember when he was in
jail he was thinking a little bit
different
and i i think i i think i sent him if
i'm not mistaken
um i don't know if we sent him i sent
him a quran if i sent to his jail i'm
not sure
if but we reached out and gave a message
to him you know because that opportunity
when people
are in jail you know all the
distractions
are away from you now it's time to
really think and ponder
yeah now i remember it was the brother
from the uk uh
another bachelor that gave him a quran
and and some books
and uh also um he wanted to take a
picture with
uh his wife him and his wife and floyd
and floyd you know
because he he took like floyd's was
going to be in the middle of the picture
but floyd you know out of respect
he got a hijab on and everything he he
wanted to be in between them
but i mean he got a lot of respect
martial allah